y poco a poco este festival de cannes
número 74 se acerca a su fin de hecho la
sección paralela a una cierta mirada hoy
fue exhibida la última película en
competencia de la salvadoreña mexicana
tatiana o hueso una película que cuenta
la historia un pequeño pueblo de montaña
en méxico acosado por el narcotráfico y
por el ejército muchas niñas son
raptadas de sus hogares por lo mismo sus
madres les cortan el pelo muy muy corto
para que parezcan chicos y no chicas los
la realizador estuvo presente durante la
proyección y explicó que este es su
primer filme de ficción antes se
dedicaba al documental y eso se nota
sobre todo en la bella fotografía de la
película que fue recibida con una gran
ovación y decimos que este festival se
acerca a su fin porque por ejemplo en la
semana de la crítica ya se entregaron
los premios el premio principal se lo
llevó la película plumas del egipcio
omar el sahili y un premio de
interpretación para la colombiana sandra
melissa torres protagonista de la
película amparo decimos mesa